Joe and writing poetry is being down on
your hands and knees with the language
you know if someone carbs swans and
animals out of soap and that person
loves soap and if you write you love the
language so it's an opportunity writing
a poem is an opportunity to get as close
to the languages pretty much you can get
the other joy because it is a pleasure
and I wouldn't I have no hi mission that
drives me to write poetry it is a very
hedonistic activity and i get i write it
for pleasure I go there to get pleasure
and and if possible to give pleasure so
one of the key pleasures is and most
poets would would would agree with this
is starting out not knowing where you're
going and finding a way to get there so
the poem becomes not a whole expression
of something you think or feel but it
becomes a journey through itself to an
ending and that ending is unforeseeable
and in fact the ending is something that
the poem is busy creating it's almost as
if the poem is the only way to access
that's that particular ending I have a
poem called questions about angels and
at the end of that poem an angel appears
and I didn't know she existed before I
write that wrote that poem and I guess
strictly speaking she didn't so I think
of that poem as simply the job of that
poem is to bring her into being to bring
its own ending into being when you're
not writing there's an anxiety about
whether you will write again of all the
kinds of writers well at least compared
to playwrights and novelists poets
return to the blank page more frequently
and you know a novel can take you six
months or five years to write but a poem
you know can get
an afternoon or a couple of days and
then you're back to zero and you have to
restart from nothing and at that point
the question comes up I mean can you
restart can you boot yourself up again
so to speak or was that it so that that
is probably the main anxiety I think
that goes with poetry writing is heavier
exposure to the blank page or regular
encounters with blankness I just go poem
by poem I don't have an overarching a
sense of a book as a project I probably
have a manuscript I do have a manuscript
of poems that is just about ready and
I'm just you don't want to send it out
too early it probably needs maybe two or
three at the most really strong good
poems and then it'll be ready and so I'm
just interested in getting that out of
the house and maybe starting upon this
afternoon or or next Wednesday you know
when /
you